miles de personas evacuadas y cientos de
casas destruidas
las calles de coltauco en el centro de
chile están bajo el agua el río maule
las autoridades ya reportan
desaparecidos
[Música]
un terremoto de agua un terremoto de
agua que
los ganó por todos lados
[Música]
los ganó y ahora tenemos que sacar
fuerzas de a dónde podemos
las inundaciones causadas por las
lluvias se intensificaron desde el fin
de semana el país austral está viviendo
un invierno inusual afectado por el
fenómeno del niño según científicos de
la Universidad de chile la temperatura
del Pacífico ecuatorial va en aumento
como consecuencia en lugares donde antes
nevaba ahora llueve y en exceso una de
las consecuencias del cambio climático
el presidente Gabriel boric visitó las
zonas afectadas ha pasado muy mal
y hoy día lo que les importa es que las
ayudas lleguen que el estado esté
presente pero también ustedes han visto
la solidaridad de los vecinos es
fundamental el pueblo es antes del
desbordamiento del río maule el río
mapocho que atraviesa Santiago de Chile
y que suele estar seco creció luego de
dos días de intensas lluvias y causó la
evacuación de casi 400 personas